This next story is almost beyond belief. The
post facto smear campaign by the right against
right winger, John Bolton, Donald Trump's
former national security advisor is growing
in ways that might even surprise a regular
follower of right-wing propaganda channels
like Fox news.
Let me recap and then we'll get into unbelievable
video from Lou Dobbs. So to recap, John Bolton
recently said, Trump told me, hold the aid
to Ukraine until they, uh, come out and smear
Biden publicly. There is now a battle over
whether John Bolton should or will testify
in the Senate impeachment trial of Donald
Trump. Friday. There's going to be a debate
and a vote about that in the Senate based
on the schedule. We know right now, we'll
tell you ultimately whether four or more Republicans
do the right thing and vote for John Bolton
to testify. But in the meantime, right wingers
are smearing John Bolton, including pretending
that John Bolton is some kind of anti-Trump,
a bomb throwing leftist, which if you were
around during the era of the Iraq war, you
would know that suggesting that John Bolton
is any kind of tool of the left is a comically
ridiculous claim.
Check this out from the Lou Dobbs show on
fire. I think he's on Fox business, not Fox
news proper, where Lou Dobbs devoted an entire
segment to smearing Bolton as a tool of the
radical left. This is not satire. This is
not Saturday night live. The architect of
the Iraq war, one of the most evil warmongering
Republican reactionaries of the last 20 years
of American foreign policy. John Bolton is
now being smeared as a tool of the left on
Fox because he simply believes from his lying
and Trump is dangerous. In this clip, you're
going to see Lou Dobbs present a whacked out
conspiracy theory where Mitt Romney is also
a part of the plot to take down Trump by pushing
for Bolton's testimony. You've got to see
it to believe it. It actually takes some effort
to even follow this. Check it out. Lu, putting
up those conspiratorial spider charts where
everything's linked, the likes of which you
often see on YouTube channels. Talking about
George Soros conspiracy theories. Take a look
at this.
Mitt Romney, have I said that name before
here tonight? Yes. I have Mitt Romney's call
for John Bolton's. Testimony comes as no surprise.
Romney has been, let's say wobbly throughout
his long had connections with foreign policy
rhinos and they with him. Bolton, one of the,
he served as Romney's foreign policy advisor
during Romney's failed 2012 presidential run
and current national security advisor. Robert
O'Brian also served as a foreign policy advisor
to Romney O'Brian. Also worked with Bolton
at the United nations when Bolton was the
U S ambassador, both Bolton and O'Brian led
the national security council that employed
the likes of the infamous anonymous whistle
blower and never Trumper Lieutenant Colonel
Alex amendment and his brother. You have GenY
Veneman, the security council, senior ethics
lawyer.
Okay, so so far Lou Dobbs has speculatively
and circumstantially linked and I use that
term linked very loosely. Mitt Romney to John
Bolton. And an impeachment witness, Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander Veneman, who also has been
widely smeared by the right despite the right
planning that they support and trust members
of the military. A Lieutenant Colonel Veneman,
a longtime member of the military, they are
smearing him as well. So let's continue. And
now this is the key line, the claim from blue
Dobbs that John Bolton is a tool of the left
and something funny also happens in this clip,
which also happens to Rudy Giuliani. When
he is going on these conspiracy rants. Lou
Dobbs sort of starts to lose his train of
thought and at the end of the next clip he
starts to stumble and make no sense. But the
key thing, he refers to John Bolton, outrageous
right-wing reactionary as a tool for the radical
left.
See how it works. You bet. Not so complicated,
is it? John Bolton himself has been reduced
to a tool for the radical Dems and the deep
state with his, well, his allegation that
the president once told him that the the aid
to the, to the Ukraine was entirely dependent
on whether or not mr Zelinsky carried out
investigations of his political consider
the revisionist history. Republicans have
loved and trusted John Bolton for decades.
Bolton was a key designer of the Iraq war
and now Bolton is simply saying, I'm not going
to stand by Trump. I want to tell what I believe
to be the truth in the impeachment trial.
The way he is telling it in his book, he is
out the right does not tolerate traders. But
I don't mean they don't tolerate traders to
the U S they gladly tolerate traders to the
U S the right doesn't tolerate traders to
their party and their movement. And by the
way, classic Lou Dobbs moment, Lou Dobbs years
ago, chiming in on the Obama 10 suit controversy.
Remember this?
I think it was shocking a lot of people. Is
this an effort to make him look warmer?
So that's Lou Dobbs for you. So understand
this point right now. Donald Trump has such
a group of Brown nosing sycophants around
him that if Dick Cheney came out and said,
I'm worried that what Donald Trump is doing
is bad for the country, you would just as
quickly see Dick Cheney called the tool for
the radical left as well. This is how unhinged
and disconnected from the facts they are and
they don't care and they'll probably get away
with it. We'll have more on this on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show on Instagram. Follow
me on Instagram while you're there at David.
Dot Pacman. Quick break after the break. Donald
Trump has glitched yet again, including um,
uh, at a, at a recent New Jersey rally. We'll
have video.
We will discuss it in just a few short minutes.